زياره تاريخيه لامير دوله قطر الشيخ حمد
بن خليفه الثاني الى قطاع غزه اليوم تحدى
فيها الحصار الاسرائيليه المفروضه على
القطاع وبذلك يكون الامير اول زعيم يزور
غزه منذ عام
حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر ل نناقشه
في عنوانين رئيسيين ما تداعيات هذه
الزياره التي كسرت الحصار الاسرائيلي
المفروضه على غزه وكيف ستؤثر المساعدات
الماليه القطريه على الجانب الاقتصادي في
القطاع اذا كسرت زياره امير قطر الشيخ حمد
بن خليفه الثاني الى قطاع غزه اليوم حاله
الجمود السياسي والحصار الاسرائيلي
المفروض على القطاع منذ عام
2007 فقد اعتبرها كثير من المراقبين بدايه
لعهد سياسي مختلف افرزه الربيع العربي فما
كان بالامس محرما بفعل الموازين الدوليه
والاقليميه اصبح اليوم ممكنا لمن يريد
التغيير
يتجنب المسؤولون الدوليون بعنايه الالتقاء
بقاده حماس عندما يزورون غزه منذ سيطرات
الحركه على مقاليد الامور هناك امير قطر
الزعيم الوحيد الذي يزور القطاع في ظروفه
السياسيه الحاليه ليست زياره مجامله اذ
تحمل معها استثمارات ومساعدات قطريه بقيمه
400 مليون دولار تنفق على مشاريع اسكانيه
وبنيه تحتيه وتطوير فلاحي وغيرها وذلك ما
يحتاجه القطاع بالضبط بعد سنين الحصار
الدولي والاقليمي وبعد دمار الحرب
الاسرائيليه نهايه العام 2008 واليوم فقد
ان الاوان كي يطوي الفلسطينيين صفحه
الخلاف ويفتحوا فصلا واسعا للمصالحه
والاتفاق وفق الاسس التي اتفقوا عليها في
الدوحه
والقاهره بجهود صادقه من الرئيس الفلسطيني
الاخ محمود عباس ورئيس المكتب السياسي
لحركه حما
الاخ خالد
مشعل اثارت الزياره حفيظه الاسرائيليين
فجاء موقف تل ابيب لاف للنظر لانه صيغ
باسلوب من يريد ان يبدو حريصا كل الحرص
على مصلحه حركه
فتح من الغريب حقا ان يختار امير قطر جانب
حماس على جانب فتح ولماذا لا يقدم الدعم
للفلسطينيين عموما وليس لحماس تحديدا ان
امير قطر بمعانقته حماس يكون القى بعمليه
السلام وراء
ظهره لكن التاريخ سجل ان امير قطر زار غزه
ايضا سنه 99 و9 عندما كان الزعيم الراحل
ياسر عرفات على قيد الحياه ولم يكن القطاع
تحت سيطره
حماس تحتفظ ذاكره الاحداث كذلك بمشهد
لامير قطر في الضاحيه الجنوبيه من بيروت
بعد الحرب الاسرائيلي عام 2006 مع التزام
الدوحه باعاده اعمار قر دمرتها اسرائيل
انذاك مع النجاح في تسويه الازمه السياسيه
اللبنانيه في مايو ايار
2008 يدرج متابعون توسع الدور القطري
الاقليمي في اطار مصطلح القوه الناعمه وهي
لا تقاس بحجم الدوله بل بمؤهلاتها وقبل
ذلك بقرار سياسي مستعد لتحمل عواقب وتبعات
ذلك
الدور لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستديو الدكتور محمد المسفر استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه قطر ومن عمان
معنا الدكتور جواد الحمد مدير مركز دراسات
الشرق الاوسط وسنناقش معهما الابعاد
السياسيه لهذه الزياره في الجزء الثاني من
الحلقه نناقش مع الخبير والمحلل الاقتصادي
في غزه الدكتور ماهر الطباع الابعاد
الاقتصاديه للزياره وابدا معك دكتور جواد
الحمد اذا هذه اول زعيم يزور قطاع غزه هل
هي نقطه تحول بالنسبه للقطاع يمكن ان يبنى
عليها عربيا
ودوليا بالتاكيد لا شك ان هذا القرار قرار
شجاع وقرار جريء وقرار يعبر عن موقف قطر
من دعم الشعب الفلسطيني والوقوف الى جانبه
ض العدوان الاسرائيلي دائما ويمثل من
ناحيه ثانيه كسرا سياسيا للحصار المفروض
على قطاع غزه باراده عربيه خالصه اساسها
دوله قطر وبتعاون مع دوله مصر بعد الثوره
ومن هنا اعتقد نعم ان هذه الزياره تمثل
انعطافا تاريخيه مهمه في التعامل العربي
مع القرارات الدوليه الظالمه تجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني والتي اساسها اليوم هو قرار
الحصار المفروض من الرباعيه الدوليه
واعتقد ان قطر سوف تجني الكثير من هذا
الموقف الشجاع لمير قطر وهو ليس موقفا
وحيدا ومنعزل وانما له مواقف سابقه وخاصه
اثناء حرب غزه عندما وقف الى جانب الشعب
الفلسطيني في غزه وعقد مؤتمر القمه ايه في
في الدوحه ما سماها ق
المقاومه ودعم المقاومه كما يعرف الجميع
طيب هل تتوقع فعلا ان يبنى عليها مثلا
نتوقع ان نرى زعماء اخرين سواء كانوا عرب
ام من اجزاء مختلفه من العالم يزورون
القطاع بعد هذه
الزياره انا اعتقد انها تفتح باب واسع
لتشجيع الرسميه العربيه للتعامل مع قطاع
غزه بعيدا عن الحصار الدولي وبعيدا عن
الخوف من الدوليه واليوم نحن امام اربع
دول عربيه خضعت لما يسمى بالثوره و تمكنت
من الوصول الى سلطات فيها بالاضافه الى
قطر ودوله السودان ودول اخرى يمكن ان تنضم
لها تشكل لوبي عربي قوي يمكنه ان يشكل
رايا عربيا حقيقيا مستقلا داعما للشعب
الفلسطيني بعيد عن الاراده الدوليه اعتقد
ان الرئيس مرسي هو المرشح الثاني لزياره
قطاع غزه وكذلك الامين العام لجامعه الدول
العربيه طيب يعني بعيدا عن الحديث عن
الانجاز او الجانب الايجابي لهذه الزياره
هناك دكتور محمد المسفر هناك تحفظ وهناك
استغراب الاستغراب ل نبدا به من الجانب
الاسرائيلي طبعا بدا كما سمعنا الانتو
الناطق باسم الخارجيه الاسرائيليه كانه
يدافع عن حماس يعني بشكل كبير او عن فتح
عفوا ويقول ان لماذا يدعم امير قطر حماس
بهذه الطريقه على حساب فتح ويقول يبدو
وكان امير قطر اريد ان استعمل الكلمات
باحتضانه حماس وكانه يلقي بعمليه السلام
وراء ظهره ما
تعلك بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه و تقدير
لهذه الجهود العربيه التي يقودها سمو
الامير بذهابه الى غزه ونقدم التهاني ايضا
ل مشاهدي الجزيره بحلول مناسبه
الاعياد عيد الحج او العيد الكبير لهذا
العام نقول بانها نحن في مرحله متغيره من
التاريخ بهذه الخطوه الجريئ وبان امير قطر
لم يكن كما يقولون الاسرائيليين بانه جانب
عمليه السلام كان اول زعيم عربي يذهب الى
غزه مؤيدا لحركه السلام الذي وقع عليها
السيد ياسر عرفات في عام
1999 والان وفي نفس الوقت قابل السيد او
الشيخ ياسين احمد ياسين وهو خارج من السجن
الاسرائيلي ايضا مهنيا بذلك نقول بهذا
العمل بان هذا التغير الذي حدث اليوم بان
يزور الامير امير الوله قطر يرافقه زوجه
ويرافقه اولاده وكثير من اسرته ايضا الى
جانب رئيس الوزراء معنى ذلك هو فتح الباب
من جديد دعما للسلام وليس دعما للحرب ولكن
في هذا الموقف من الذي يجانب الصواب من
الذي يسير في تيار الحرب
بقيام بغزوات بقيام بهجوم على غزه بشكل
يومي ومتتابع غير الاسرائيليين الذين
يقولون باننا نحن نجعل سلام خارج الا ولكن
دكتور هناك اطراف فلسطينيه ايضا ابدت بعض
التحفظ بشان هذه الزياره و اعربت عن
خشيتها من انها تكرس الانقسام الفلسطيني
الفلسطيني الذي يكرس الانفصال الفلسطيني
الفلسطيني ويكرس القطيعه هي السلطه
الفلسطينيه بقياده محمود عباس ا تم
الاتصال به وتم التعامل معه وتم التمني
بان يكون مرافقا في هذه السفره الى غزه
ليكون فتحا جديدا في عمليه السلام في
عمليه المصالحه الوطنيه ولكنه ابى ذلك
الامر الاخر انه اجتمع هو هو والسيد مشعل
في غزه ووقعوا اتفاقيه كما وقعوا اتفاقيه
في القاهره كما وقعوا اتفاقيه في مكه ولكن
من ينقضها في واقع الامر الذي ينقضها هو
ما يسمى بالسلطه الفلسطينيه بقياده محمود
عباس ورفاقه وليس اذا دكتور الدكتور جواد
الحمد اين نحن فعليا من مصالحه فلسطينيه
هل هذ هذه الزياره تقربنا منها باي شكل من
الاشكال انا اعتقد ان الزياره بمكاسبها
الكبيره للقضيه فلسطينيه وللشعب الفلسطيني
سوف تشكل ضغطا كبيرا على القوه الفلسطينيه
وخاصه الامير المح في خطابه الى هذه
المساله بوضوح وخاصه لحركه حماس بانه ي
انا الاوان لانهاء الازمه الداخليه
الفلسطينيه وتشكيل حكومه فلسطينيه واحده
وقد اتفق الطرفان على ان يسها السيد محمود
عباس وتلك في تشكيلها حتى الان و
يصبح الموقف الفلسطيني موقفا سياسيا واحدا
امام العالم لان قضيه التمثيل والشرعيه قد
اثقلت ظهر و وكاهن القضيه الفلسطينيه
دوليا وعربيا وكانت حجه الحقيقه لكثير من
العرب ان لا يدعم الشعب الفلسطينيه بسبب
هذا الانقسام اليوم امير قطر دعا بوضوح
الى انهاء الانقسام وامل ان يتمكن من
تقديم مبادره تقوم مع برنامج سياسي واضح
لاعاده بناء حكومه فلسطينيه واحده واستمر
ار التوافق الفلسطيني الداخلي على مختلف
المسائل المفتوحه امامنا للتفرغ ل تبني
القضيه ال فلسطينيه والاستفاده ايضا من
الربيع العربي والثورات العربيه التي
اصبحت يمكن ان تحتضن القضيه الفلسطينيه
على قاعده مشروع تحرير فلسطين وهو الامر
الذي غاب عقودا مضت كما يعرف الجميع طيب
اريد ان اتوقف عند نقطه دكتور جواد الحمد
اشار اليها بعض المحللين ان الدعم او ما
فسره البعض على انه دعم لحماس هو في
الواقع هو محاوله استيعاب
لحماس من من جانب قطر هل توافق على هذا
التحليل على كل حال الناس تحلل كما تشاء
الحقيقه ان دوله قطر موقفها من القضيه
الفلسطينيه موقف مبدئي ولم نرى له زحزحه
منذ حكومه الامير حمد حتى الان ثانيا قطر
وقفت مع حماس في ظرف حالك وصعب جدا في حرب
غزه عام 2009 كما يعرف الجميع القضيه
الثالثه ان دعم الشعب الفلسطيني اصلا مقرر
في الجامعه العربيه ولم يكن هناك جراه ولا
شجاعه من قبل النظام العربي ومختلف دوله
في حينها لكسر الحصار السياسي المفروض
وتقديم الدعم الذي توفر في صناديق الدعم
العربيه في الجامعه العربيه اليوم امير
قطر دق الجرس واتخذ القرار الشجاع وتقدم
خطوه على كل الصف العربي ولذلك لا داعي
للبحث عن منغصات لهذه الخطوه الايجابيه
والكبيره لدعم الشعب الفلسطيني وحكومته
على موضوع الدعم الاقتصادي وهل طيب الدعم
الاقتصادي سنركز عليه ولكن دكتور محمد
مسفر اريد ان اسمع منك انت ايضا رايا فيما
يتعلق بهذا الاستيعاب الذي اشار اليه بعض
المحللين صراحه لحماس يعني الان انا اعتقد
انها
يعني وصلنا الى نقطه محدده وهو الان تحدي
امام الزعماء العرب بكامل كنا يعني نعيب
على حركه حماس بانها مرتم في احضان ايران
وكنا نعيب على حركه حماس بانه مرتم في
احضان النظام السوري الان سوريا وايران في
مازق مازق سياسي مازق اقتصادي مازق كل شيء
اذا الان خرجت حماس من سوريا وخرجت حماس
من طهران لعلم وبالتالي نقول انه على
الدوره العربي الان ان يحتضنوا حماس وان
يقوموا بالدافع لها من اجل اعاده بناء غزه
والدفع بحماس وحركه فتح بالتف فاوض
والوصول الى عمليه المصالحه الوطنيه
وتحقيق الوحده الوطنيه كما جاء في خطاب
سمو الامير في غزه والذي يخاطب به ذلك
الامر الاخر بانها ليست عمليه احتواء
وانما هي عمليه دعوه الان بان غزه نقطه
الانطلاق للوحده الوطنيه الفلسطينيه هي
مكمنها في غزه اذا كان هناك اراده سياسيه
لحركه فتح او للسلطه الفلسطينيه بقياده
محمود عباس فال خطوه الجريئه والشجاعه ان
يذهب
هو وفصيله الى غزه وتبدا عمليه المصالحه
دون العواصم العربيه ولكن على الارض
الفلسطينيه وبذلك يقفون التحدي الذي
يواجههم مع اسرائيل طيب هناك ايضا نقطه
اخرى ربما انت ذكرت على سوريا وايران الان
في مازق ولكن هناك من يقول ان القضيه
الفلسطينيه في الواقع في مازق بسبب ان
العالم العربي كله والعالم كله منشغل
بموضوع الربيع العربي والثورات وما الى
ذلك و وفي الواقع يعني القضيه الفلسطينيه
اخذت دور يعني خلفي هل هذه الزياره برايك
تساهم في اعاده هذه القضيه الواجه اعطائها
ما تستحقه من اهتمام من جديد انا اعتقد
انه وسائل الاعلام العالميه اليوم كلها
انشغلت بهذه الزياره لو تسمعين جميع محطات
العالم الان لا تتحدث الا عن زياره امير
قطر لغزه والموقف الوطني الذي تقدم به
والخطاب الشجاع الذي قال به بان هناك بعض
القيادات العربيه لم تفي بالتزاماتها تجاه
المصالحه وتجاه اعاده اعمار غزه وانه
يناشد هذا ايضا للعالم كله يتحدث عن هذه
الزياره انا اعتقد انها ردت القضيه الى ما
يسمى بدائره الضوء الدوليه بان مكمن مازه
الشرق الاوسط هي القضيه الفلسطينيه
والدعوه الحقيقيه من قبل القياده انه لابد
من وحده فلسطينيه حقيقيه دون المراهنه على
ما يسمى بخطوات المجامله لاسرائيل او لغير
ذلك طبعا في النهايه هناك جانب سياسي ولكن
هناك جانب اقتصادي لذا الموضوع ماذا يعني
وماذا تعني هذه الزياره بالنسبه للمواطن
الفلسطيني في القطاع هذا ما سنسال بعد
الفاصل ارجو تبق
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد نرحب بكم ونرحب من
جديد بضيف فنا في غزه المحلل والخبير
الاقتصادي الدكتور ماهر الطباع ربما الان
نركز على الجانب الاقتصادي لزياره امير
قطر لقطاع غزه يعني هذه الزياره في
النهايه ماذا تعني بالنسبه لمواطن عادي
يعيش في القطاع ماذا تعني بالارقام
تسمعني دكتور ماهر الطباع الرحيم اه سامع
معك بسم الله الرحمن ال تضل اي زياره سمو
الامير الشيخ حمد
اي بن خليفه الثاني وزوجته طيب للاسف
الصوت غير واضح تماما سنحاول ان نعود
اليك ربما ايضا يعني كنت احب ان اسمع من
الدكتور ماهر طباع في هذه النقطه تحديدا
لان نتحدث
عن اكثر من 400 مليون دولار ودكتور دكتور
جواد الحمد هل تعتقد ان هذه المساعدات
يمكن ان تفتح الباب امام مساعدات عربيه
اخرى من اطراف
مختلفه اولا هذه مساعدات كبيره تعتبر
لقطاع غزه ومهمه جدا تتعلق بالاسكان
والمعيشه العامه وتحريك عجد الاقتصاد
ثانيا ان الامير قطر تمكن من اخذ موافقه
مصريه واضحه على ادخال مواد البناء
والمعدات والحديد وما ما شابه الى قطاع
غزه ايضا وهذا سيشغل قطاع البناء وقطاع
الانشاءات بشكل واسع النطاق كبير القضيه
الثالثه ان الوقود القطري ايضا بدا يدخل
قطاع غزه بانتظام وما سيفعل طاقات
الكهرباء بشكل افضل مما كانت عليه ويفعل
الجانب الصناعي وحركه المرور والحركه
التجاريه في داخل قطاع غزه بمعنى ان
النتائج المتوقعه لمثل هذا الدعم القطري
المتعدد الاوجه نتائج كبيره جدا على حياه
المواطن العادي ومعيشته اليوميه واضافه
الى الجانب التجاري اقتصادي في قطاع غزه
وهو امر كان بحاجه ما سيه القطاع في مرحله
سابقه اليوم ربما يتحقق بشكل افضل بكثير
يعني هل الاثر الاقتصادي ربما لهذه
المشاريع ينتهي بانتهائها ام سيكون لها
اثر اكبر وابعد من ذلك
برايك بالطبع الزياره والدعم الاقتصادي
والمشاريع القطريه هي البدايه وليست
النهايه بالتاكيد لان هذه كما قلت قبل
قليل هو كسر للحصار السياسي وكسر وانهاء
بل للحصار الاقتصادي وبالتالي هناك الان
فرصه سانحه جدا ولكن ولكن دكتور لنتوقف
عند هذه النقطه لنتوقف يعني في النهايه
اسرائيل ما زالت تتحكم بما يدخل للقطاع
يعني كيف يمكن مثلا ان نتوقع ان تدخل
ادوات البناء و وما طلب تتطلبه هذه
المشاريع يعني ليس هناك خوف من ان اعود
لنقطه
البدايه انا استبعد حاليا ان تجرؤ اسرائيل
على شن اي هجوم حقيقي على قطاع غزه ستبقي
عمليه مناوشات لتعبئه الجبهه الداخليه
ولكنها اليوم في وضع استراتيجي صعب وقلق
بل وفيه الكثير من الخوف والترقب للمنطقه
ومن هنا اعتقد ان بناء المشاريع
الاقتصاديه في غزه اليوم يختلف الامن فيه
عن ما كان عليه قبل الربيع العربي اليوم
مصر وهذه قطر وهناك دول عربيه اخرى تلحق
في الطريق تقول لاسرائيل يجب ان تقف عند
حد الشعب الفلسطيني ليس ضربه مشاعا ولا
قتله مشاعا هذا الموقف المص المصري
والقطري والعربي العام الحقيقه من دول
الثورات العربيه والربيع العربي وبعض
الدول الاخرى اصبح يشكل رادع وانا ذكرت
اكثر من مره بان امكانيه تشكيل لوبي عربي
مجموعه من الدول اربع او خمس او ست دول
عربيه سيكون كافيا بالطبع لان تقف اسرائيل
عند حدها عندما يقولون لها لا لا نسمح
بالاعتداء على الفلسطينيين بغزه او الضفه
واعتقد ان هذه بدايه حقيقيه للموضوع
وسيكون لها ما بعدها في المرحله القادمه
اي طبعا في انتظار ان نواصل الاتصال مع
الدكتور ماهر طباع يبدو انه يسمعني الان
دكتور ماهر تسمعني ايوه صحيح معك ص ونحن
نسمعك ايضا تفضل فيما يتعلق بالمواطن
العادي الذي يعيش في القطاع ماذا يعني له
بالارقام بشكل سريع لو سمحت اي طبعا في
البدايه بنشكر الامير القطري والحكومه
القطريه والشعب القطري على المنحه السخريه
التي قدموها لقطاع غزه والمق رب 400 مليون
دولار ال 400 مليون دولار لاول مره في
تاريخ قطاع غزه يضخ مبلغ او بهذا الحجم
الكبير من خلال مشاريع استراتيجيه هامه
لقطاع غزه المنحه القطريه بالفعل
تناولت اهم المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه
اهم مشاريع البنيه التحتيه التي يعاني
منها قطاع غزه نتكلم عن شارع صلاح الدين
وهو الشارع الرئيسي في قطاع غزه نتكلم عن
شارع البحر وهو المتنفس الوحيد لسكان قطاع
غزه نتكلم عن مستشفى للاطراف الصناعيه
تعرفين ان هناك العديد من الاصابات نتيجه
المقاومه ونتيجه الحرب يصعب علاجها في
قطاع غزه هذه سوف تساهم بشكل كبير في
اعاده الحياه للعديد
من المصابين في قطاع غزه نتيجه المق
مقاومه نتيجه الحرب اي المدن السكنيه التي
تبرعت بها قطر نحن هناك عجز في الاسكان في
قطاع غزه او في المدن السكنيه يزيد عن
30,000 وحده سكنيه المنحه القطريه
اي سوف تساهم في فك الحصار المفروض على
قطاع غزه منذ اقصى من خمس سنوات قطاع غزه
يعاني من نسبه بطاله تزيد عن
30%
المنحه القطريه والمشاريع القطريه المقامه
في قطاع غزه والتي سوف تقام في قطاع غزه
طيب بشكل سريع هلك تعليق على قضيه دخول
المواد التي تحتاج هذه المشاريع الى قطاع
غزه
طبعا نحن نعرف ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي بعد حصار قطاع غزه اغلق كافه
المعابر التجاريه وابقى على معبر كرم ابو
سالم كمعبر وحيد لدخول البضائع حت حتى
يومنا هذا الجانب الاسرائيلي يتحكم بدخول
بدخول البضائع الى قطاع غزه يمنع دخول
كافه انواع مواد البناء الى قطاع غزه يمنع
كافه دخول الاليات والمعدات
الخاصه
بالانشاءات يمنع
دخول ماده الاسفلت المطلوبه لل
للشوارع هناك معيقات لكن كما سمعنا ان
هناك اتفاق مع الجانب المصري بان يتم دخول
كافه ما يلزم الى المشاريع القطريه عن
طريق الجانب المصري نحن لا نعول على
دخولها من الجانب الاسرائيلي بقدر ما نعول
على دخول كافه ما يلزم المشاريع القطريه
من الجانب المصري لان اسرائيل سوف ترفض
وبشده وتفرض قيود عديده على دخول تلك او
المواد لانها تريد ان تبقي قطاع غزه في
حاله فقر شديد في حال ارتفاع معدلات
البطاله لا تريد اي انتعاش اقتصادي في
قطاع غزه
تفضلي اشكرك دكتور ماهر الطباع يعني هل
تعتقد دكتور محمد مس ان هناك ضمانات فعلا
لدخول هذه المواد ومن ثم تحقيق هذه
المشاريع حتى نرى اثر فعلي على الارض انا
اعتقد انه لابد ان يكون موقف مصر واضحا من
هذه المساله والاعتماد الكلي الان بعد وضع
الما
الماده الماليه ووضع المخطط وضع البرنامج
لدعم غزه واعاده اعمار غزه يبقى علينا دور
مصر وهنا يعني التقدير الذي تفضل به سمو
الامير بالاشاعه برئيس الجمهوريه المصريه
الدكتور مرسي والشعب المصري والجيش المصري
في التعاون من اجل اعاده اعمار غزه ووصول
هذا الوفد الكبير الى الى غزه انا اعتقد
ان الدور الكبير الان على مصر وربما ايضا
نختم بسؤال فقط الدكتور محمد المسفر يتعلق
بنقطه كررها الامير اثناء الزياره اكثر من
مره وهي تتعلق بان الانقسام هو اكبر عدو
للشعب الفلسطيني هل تتوقع فعلا مصالحه
فلسطينيه فلسطينيه قريبا ودور لقطر فيها
انا لا اعتقد انه سيكون هناك مصالحه على
الاطلاق في ظل وجود محمود عباس على السلطه
او
مجود ما يسمى بالصلح مع اسرائيل لانه هناك
خطين مخت مفين خط مواجهه ومقاومه وخط
مصالحه ومسالمه مع الاسرائيليين
والاسرائيليون معروف موقفهم وهو عمليه
التوسع الاستيطاني التوسع في التمدد في
الضفه الغربيه والقطاع بكل اصلي في الضفه
الغربيه وفي القدس على وجه التحديد
وبالتالي لن يكون هناك اي موقف من السلطه
الفلسطينيه لانها مرتبطه ارتباطا كاملا
بمستقبلها على اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
دكتور المسفر استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه قطر وشكرا جزيلا من عمان للدكتور
جواد الحمد مدير مركز دراسات الشرق الاوسط
وضيفنا من غزه الخبير والمحلل الاقتصادي
الدكتور ماهر الطباع وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر في مان
الله
ه